Hillary Clinton just weighed in on the
heat wave that we're experiencing and
she said quote hot enough for you thank
a Maga Republican or better yet vote
them out of office
Hillary Clinton you know she's the adult
in charge she's the really serious
person and this very serious person is
saying that summer heat waves
a feature of life for all of history
are the fault of Republicans and not
those Mitt Romney Republicans by the way
not those nice little Republicans who
Swish and help out the Democrats the
Mago Republicans the conservatives
conservatives are responsible for the
weather we don't control the weather we
don't control the heat it's been hot in
July forever and uh Donald Trump is not
responsible for that at all